Film Courage: How did you spend your first
few years as a screenwriter?
I know you said you initially wanted to be
an actor?
And I know you’ve had a career as a musician
but how did you spend your first few years
as an actual screenwriter?
How is it for you now?
Is it the same (just more year behind you
in terms of what you don’t like, what you
do like?
Shawn Christensen, co-screenwriter/producer
of THE VANISHING OF SIDNEY HALL movie: It’s
much different….so when I first wrote screenplays,
you are writing it for the fun of the medium
or you want to write movies or be in the film
business or you have a great story to tell,
whatever your reasons are (a combination of
all those things).
But what happened for me is we had an agent
as I said from this little script and once
you have an agent especially if you are at
a big agency like WME [William Morris Endeavor]
you have access and when you have access it
charges you to…now you know you can really
write, because you know you can get the screenplay
to people.
It’s a different thing.
And so I wrote a couple bigger movies, bigger
in…action movies I guess we’ll call them.
And these movies went into the big studios
and they went through the engine (The Factory).
And the writer can get really destroyed in
that Factory.
And I got destroyed in that Factory.
It doesn’t happen all the time but I wrote
a couple popcorn movies and they got rewritten
head-to-toe.
One of them didn’t get made, one did.
But it was an excruciating experience and
it really quite frankly made me not want to
write anymore.
That’s really when I got into directing
because my feeling was I don’t know if I’m
a good director but I really don’t know
if I’m a good writer (was the thing)?
So maybe if I shoot my words myself like a
short film.
I’ll know if I really belong here or not,
you know?
And I did this short film called BRINK which
didn’t have a lot of dialogue in it.
It was a very short film, kind of a sci-fi
romance, real quiet film, beautiful music
by my composer Darren Morze.
I actually made the film based on his music.
And it was refreshing because as I said it
didn’t have a lot of dialogue so I really
didn’t have a script, I didn’t write a
script for this film.
And it was fun to just direct something, not
write it because I really didn’t think I
was a good writer at that point.
And it was nice to just work with friends.
I had a camera and we shot this short film
and we started just doing short films and
myself and my producing partner Damon Russell
and then I got into directing.
And that kind of rounded me back to liking
to write again because I realized that I can
have confidence in some of what I do.
I don’t have confidence in most of what
I do but I can have confidence in writing
again once I started directing.